howdy folks it's Jerry coming at you on
your computer screen or wherever else
you might be watching from I am just
heading home from Ryan's and I figured
I'd stop it was a little movie review
because guess what there's a big old
movie out this weekend that's right you
guessed it i'm talking about ant-man the
newest entry into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe the end of Phase two which a
lot of people don't really I didn't
realize until I forgive me for
forgetting but somebody corrected me
ant-man is the end of Marvel's phase two
uh not the avengers age of ultron but
ant-man because apparently ant-man is
going to be in drool uh to the rest of
the MCU for here on out or at least for
phase 3 so let's get into this ant-man
is kind of your traditional origin story
of a superhero movie you know it's about
a pretty competent thief who's hit a run
of bad luck he's just getting out of
jail he's divorced from his wife you
know he's not allowed to see his
daughter you know things just ain't
working out for Scott man and along the
way as circumstances become more dire as
his job at baskin-robbins isn't working
out he turns back once again to a life
of crime and it is through this that he
comes in contact with Hank Pym the
ant-man up let's start out you know the
cast is usually a good place to start um
I really like
so how is this movie let's get into it
the guy next to me has a giant penis
that's why his car is so loud so that
you can hear his penis coming where
every my room and yeah how's this movie
well let's start I feel like it's
appropriate to start with Paul Rudd
because you know people are wondering
about this movie it's kind of a kooky
concept and it's kind of an interesting
choice for who should play the lead role
in something like this perhaps a
sensible choice for the more comedic
aspirations of this movie but you know
given that this is a Marvel Cinematic
Universe film it's a little interesting
to see Paul Rudd starring in something
like this you know them going into a
more overtly comedic zone and I think
Paul Rudd is good in this i'm happy to
report back I think Paul Rudd does a
good job he plays the character very
earnestly he's got a sense of humor but
he's a likeable guy and his motives are
likeable and he's super competent at
what he does even though he's on the
wrong side of the law you can get behind
him he's not a Tony Stark type like he's
got you know a whit about him in a sense
of humor but he's not a narcissistic
train wreck um so it's a nice contrast
there and I think Paul Rudd handles this
role really well and I'm happy to see
him further down the line as the phase
three of Marvel Cinematic Universe
progresses Michael Douglas is in this as
well Michael Douglas place Hank Pam the
original ant-man who's passing along the
mantle and i gotta say he's great in
this i mean you forget about michael
douglas sometimes but he showed up in
this end and i really like the way he
played this I think he does a great job
he's really believable he brings a
certain level of charm but also just a
certain level of gravity and you believe
this guy really well done on his part i
mean i think michael douglas is great in
this you know he's definitely a
highlight then we have Corey Stoll who
you may recognize from things like
health two cards um playing the villain
and I like him in this movie too um he's
playing a villain for sure like you can
tell this guy's evil the second he walks
on screen but what I do appreciate about
him is that he is really committed to
this to the point where it in one scene
when part of his plan is foiled you can
actually
his eyes are watering he's tearing up
like you can tell that even though this
guy is off yeah clearly this guy is
gonna do some unsavory things Corey
Stoll is really invested in it and that
goes a long way and it helps that the
script actually does acknowledge you
know that this character is sort of
mentally unstable you know through the
Michael Douglas character they sort of
address that this guy is a bit
unbalanced and that goes along like cuz
I'm you know we've had a lot of villains
who are just kind of evil just cuz and
it was nice just to have a little bit of
a human element in this guy moving
forward I mean the supporting characters
are what bring the most pure fun to this
especially when you get down to Michael
Pena TI and David dust malkin those guys
bring so much color to this movie and
they're not in a whole ton there's kind
of a period where they disappear for a
while but they play into the plot in
really fun ways you know they help this
to feel more like a heist movie Marvel's
get it crashing genres together with
superhero to keep things interesting and
those guys are part of the heist you
know you've got this sort of tech savvy
computer guy played by david does
Malcolm you've got TI who's like the
wheelman you know getaway driver and
then you've got Michael Pena who sort of
your inside guy pulling strings while I
stood under you have very different
personalities but they're really fun and
funny and it's refreshing in a way to
see a group of thieves who are just so
good-natured and kind of friendly like
that just it brought it a nice dose of
heart and personality to this it's just
different from what we're used to
getting you know it I like anti-heroes
and I like gruff characters but for this
movie it seemed really nice to have Paul
Rudd and his group it's just kind of the
most good-natured thieves ever like I
just like that about this you know kind
of gave it a plucky personality that I
can get behind us em Bobby Cannavale II
and judy greer as Scott's ex-wife and
her new beau who you know Scott is no
stranger to they're both good and in
fact I like the way they played Bobby
Cannavale II because that is an easy
character to be cheap with that's an
easy character to turn into just a dick
and they managed to make things work
because while you do like Paul Rudd you
get where this guys coming from and
while you get where this guy's coming
from you see that he's
kind of a dick in a realistic way you
know you get there friction and you get
why I'm and Judy Greer is good I mean
she's it's kind of the same role she
played in Jurassic world like she's good
at it like a glad she's here it's bummer
e to kind of always have her showing up
as like side wife but you know it's
always nice to see her and the last but
not least I'm sure you're saying
yourself Jerry you forgetting someone
and you're wrong and you're right um
reverse that I saved Evangeline Lilly
for last because I really especially
appreciated what she did here and I
wanted to put it that way so I i really
liked what they did with Evangeline
Lilly I mean off the bat I think her
performance is spot-on she does a really
good job especially because some of
those scenes are a bit truncated for as
much trouble and controversy as there
has been about Marvel and their struggle
to bring a solid female character to
screen I was so thrilled to see this
because i think they pulled it off well
with her she is clearly capable the
movie never feels the need to google her
or cheap in her and when it comes right
down to it she is the most well equipped
capable character from the onset of this
movie she can clearly take care of
herself and Paul Rudd even points out at
one point that she is she's the one
you're looking for not me you know like
she's the one who ultimately ends up
training Paul Rudd Michael Douglas does
too but she does a lot of the physical
training and you know you've all seen it
in the trailer she's showing him out a
punch and she just deck some right in
the face and as that montage continues
they allow the two of them to fight and
they both land it's on each other and
it's never made a deal out of the movie
doesn't forced her into low-cut spandex
or anything like that and it just allows
her to be a character with some real
character moments and I really
appreciated that I'm hoping to see her
of the future moving forward into the
meat of this movie here's sort of where
I'm at right now um I really enjoyed it
and there are some things that made me
feel very warm you know I had moments
watching this where i felt like i was
watching the first spider-man you know i
haven't had one of those moments in a
while because especially marvel like you
know the stakes are getting higher as
they always do in superhero movies and
you know Captain America Winter Soldier
I really like the Avengers movies i
really liked and those had humor but
they're also very dark there's
a lot at stake there's a lot of heavy
stuff going on and this one had the
Wonder again and it's hard to get back
to that because we're all so accustomed
to it especially when they do the scenes
where he's learning the suit and
learning how to do the different powers
those were just so much fun and it kind
of took me back to something like a
spider man and that's another place
where the humor tends to shine in this
movie now I think there's a problem we
have right now with superhero movies
because they are so fixed in the
marketplace and we get so many of them
that I feel like the first act has
become something that is a little tricky
because everybody knows the beats of
most of these origin stories so I get
the desire to brush past it but it does
kind of make your movie lopsided and as
I was sitting through the first half
hour or so in this movie I did find
myself sort of being like you know I
know that you know that we know but I
kind of wish it could have just unfolded
more like a natural movie a lot of the
scenes in the first act are very quick
it's almost like a yeah yeah yeahs
approach to telling those parts of the
story to setting things up not there are
cool moments or funny beads but the
introductions are all really quick we
cut in for the obligatory of six line
scene where the daughter is expressing
to her mother how much she wants dad to
come back like there are a lot of really
blocky like expositional moments the
first part of the movie so I think first
acts are something we have to figure out
again for superhero movies because it
just felt a little rushed to me and
that's something that does kind of go
throughout the movie there are a lot of
scenes I just wish had continued a bit
or had some room to breathe we don't
need to clip along quite so fast and I
know it's a two-hour movie and I have
complained about run time before but
they're just a number of scenes that
feel truncated thankfully most of them
are saved by the cast but you know that
is a legitimate complaint about this
movie throughout but most especially in
the first act that's your character
right there that's the stuff we have to
care about and and it's to the movies
credit that by the end I did actually
care about Paul Rudd and his daughter
and that dynamic of the family the ideas
of those scenes
the elements in those scenes are good
but compared to other scenes that get to
go on longer they kind of feel like
afterthoughts or feel like they were the
first thing is to get paired down when
time was needed estranged from my
daughter you know is strange for my wife
like that's a very now sort of action
movie like oh hey here's the reason why
we care about him because he cares about
something kind of story and it it does
work here partly just because the actors
are so earnest with it um they really
sell it and I liked it this time around
so props to them for that the movie
really finds its legs when Paul Rudd it
finally gets in the suit and shrinks for
the first time like that's when the
movie sort of settles on a groove and
it's also when some of the most fun and
interesting stuff happens because you
know part of what's cool about superhero
movies is that they show you something
magnificent and spectacular and is nice
to see something new again you know
because lately a lot of the fantastical
isn't as exciting just because they're
only so many ways to make superhero
fresh and this was a cool power that you
know played with the laws of physics so
was something new to see this is kind of
a quirky idea and the movie acknowledges
that you know for the first part your
hair like it was a little silly like
he's running around with ants and stuff
and they got ants doing all these things
but it does a good job acclimating you
and that's some of the most fun and
enjoyable stuff about this movie is when
they're playing with size and scope some
of the macro photography is really cool
and kind of gorgeous at a certain point
and also they get some humorous mileage
out of that you know you've all seen in
the trailer that moment where it's like
this big train crash as they're fighting
on the track and it's just a toy like
that stuff was really fun to me one
thing I really appreciate about Marvel
especially you know moving forward is
that they seem like they want to marry
each of these movies to a different
genre as well as superhero this time
around they mix superhero with heist and
I really enjoyed they brought that
element into this it gives the superhero
formula just a little added freshness
however overall just as a film I do
think that this movie struggles a bit
when it comes to tone there are
definitely some good instances of comedy
good moments of action
some really cool heist sequences and
cool superhero stuff along the way as
well but i feel like the tones at work
in this movie only ever come together
and fuse intermittently especially with
some of the humor that's given to paul
rudd specifically this movie is kind of
a good example to me anyway of clashing
approaches to humor there's your your
joke based comedy which is you know you
just wrote somebody a funny quip and
then there's character comedy which
simply comes from characters reacting
the way that character would react and
so in this movie I feel like the
character comedy is really good that's
the stuff that felt the most natural and
that made me laugh the hardest all the
stuff with Paul Rudd's crew it's like
those guys are kind of kooky characters
and because of that because the movie
establishes there were these kind of
quirky guys just their worldview is
funny and the way they behave is funny
um and that stuff really works but there
are times just kind of at the end of
scenes it feels like they'll tack on a
joke or like a funny quip for hell rug
to say and those were really hitting
this for me like none of them were bad
but a lot of them just didn't hit and
kind of felt a little awkward so that's
just kind of obscene where things stores
start to come apart a little bit
sometimes the humor and the heist in the
superhero the action are all working
together and other times they're sort of
coming apart or one is being favored
more than the other in a way that
doesn't quite work I know I'm gonna take
flack for this but that's the one place
where I really miss Edgar Wright on this
he's credited with the script and stuff
like that him and Joe Cornish I don't
know how far this draft is from theirs
but uh that's where I really miss Edgar
Wright is I feel like had Edgar Wright
been able to direct this movie he's a
master at spinning several genre plates
at once in keeping them all going it's
like if you watch hot fuzz hot fuzz has
elements of action comedy horror various
things and that movie those all fused
watching this I felt sort of the weight
of his absence every time the genres
would come apart basically Peyton Reed
definitely brings some shops to the
table there is some good time in here
there are some really creative visual
sequences especially what Michael Pena
is like telling Paul Rudd the intimate
details of like what he
heard from this guy who's got a plan
about this heist there are some really
fun clever little things thrown in but
ultimately I feel like this movie would
have sung if it had been done by Edgar
Wright just because that guy has such an
errant knack for rhythm and visuals and
pace he always brings a very human chord
things ant-man i think is pretty good i
left feeling good having enjoyed myself
i left with a lot of goodwill it
definitely won me over it struggles to
get off the ground a little bit and it
hits a little bit of turbulence along
the way but what it lacks in certain
elements of finesse it makes up for in
just sort of the freshness and the
wonder of you know the scope changes you
know shrinking the world down then
bringing it back to normal size like all
that stuff is fun the cast is really
good on and of all the Marvel movies we
had of light it was the one that felt
the most good-natured and the most fun
because even guardians of the galaxy
gets dark and kind of huh and while this
one does have all those thrill moments
there's just something about the
good-natured you know benevolence that
underlies everything that was a nice
change of pace and then I appreciate it
so overall this film is kind of scrappy
but in a way that's okay with me and a
width that almost even matches Scott
Lang to me so it's like even though the
film has its uneven in its patchy
moments it came together as a very
pleasing and good-natured whole and I I
do applaud them for that where I'm
sitting at right now I would be thrilled
to watch it again I really enjoyed
myself and I certainly hope this is one
of the more memorable ones to me just as
a little side note just something I
noticed during the film you know a lot
of the recent superhero movies there are
all these big places that they go and
the worlds are very sprawling the scope
is huge and they're always traveling
someplace different and maybe it's just
over exposure but what I started to
realize while I was watching this movie
is I really did kind of miss seeing I do
appreciate a big-budget movie like this
that sticks to a few core characters in
a few core locations and doesn't feel
the need to go someplace exotic every
ten minutes or go to another giant
cathedral-like building every 10 minutes
you know it was nice to have something a
little smaller in scale no pun intended
and not that it's small either just you
know there's a nice change of pace from
like what bar we got to go all these
places and now we're in space and now
we're in South Africa and now we're on a
flying boat you know like it was nice
obviously stay for the credits this
one's got a couple of things you should
look out for I swear but by phase for
marbles is gonna have like six boat like
mid post you know after credits Tings
they're gonna like text you a video on
the way home being like even more after
gritted [ __ ] um but yeah stay for all of
the credits let's just put it that way
yeah ant-man's a film I really enjoyed
myself let's talk about this I mean
marble seems to be getting more
sure-footed introducing some of their
more you know quirky titles titles that
would have been harder to swallow at the
beginning um so you know if you're a big
comic book fan we've had guardians of
the galaxy now we'd had ant-man now
what's another quirky Marvel book you'd
like to see brought to the big screen um
let's talk about that enlighten me I'd
love to know so until next time folks
ant-man is the film my name is Jerry
cheers